i would like to show you in this short
video how you
can calculate correlations online with data tab because the
nvidia chip
want to calculate correlations online you first have to
go to day.de and then click on the
statistics calculator
we can see here is an example
data set given if
wanted to use your own data are on the table
i have prepared data for this example here
and
i would like to look at the correlations
between height, weight and age
of some of the people interviewed
i first copy this data to you with the
statistics calculator and data pack and then
i select  down here correlation from yes
and here you can already see the
variables that are available for selection
height weight around age i
select all three
variables all three are metric
variables metric sky level that’s why
date up also beats the pierson
correlation  sco efficient before
yes and  that you already have the results
the first table gives the number of
valid cases so look at ten
cases in the second table you will find
the correlation sco efficient all
three variables height weight and
everyday life everyone with everyone
yes what can we do based on the
results  we see here on the one hand a
strong positive correlation between
height and weight at 0.86, we
have a medium-strong correlation also
positive between weight and
age at 05 23
and then we still have a rather
weak correlation between age
and height  with 0.25 what does
it mean now in terms of content, for example with
height and weight,
that would mean that a higher
height also goes hand in hand with a higher
weight and vice versa on the
right side you could then still faithfully
see diagrams that
then also visually clarify these correlations
yes and  the last balls in the result
falls is that was the k  see the correlation
coefficients again and also the significant ones,
we want to check if we discover
correlations for our sample
and whether
these can be generalized to
the
total population, which is why there is nothing significant here either, what we can see is that the correlation between height and weight is highly
significant  is because here the value is
below 5 the other two correlations
are not significant as we can see
here we are just every
probability of survival of five percent that means the correlation
between height and weight
can also be generalized
to the entire population yes that was it  Thank you
for listening and I hope you enjoyed the
video